this month's so Vegas segment I take you
on a holiday trip around the Resorts
World
it's the most enchanting holiday on the
Strip
whether you're looking for adventurous
and fun unique and Chic or how about
cool and cozy maybe you prefer glamorous
and classic Resorts World has an
experience for you making its Hallmark
as a winter holiday destination all too
often sometimes there's an absence of or
presence of holidays on Las Vegas
Boulevard so there was a real initiative
by the the leadership team here to bring
in chantific strip now on top of enchant
we wanted to have other activations
throughout the property so in the
partnership with Hallmark and and kind
of organizing and building out the
Hallmark Suite which has been a huge
success the igloo installation on Rose
rooftop even the Christmas bar at hkk we
really wanted to have a lot of different
layers that we're going to get a lot of
different consumer audiences into the
holiday spirit so let's start with
adventurous and fun and chant on the
Strip has the Beloved Christmas light
maze food and drinks in the village and
ice skating but Resorts World added some
Vegas Flair in chance we're open five
days a week right now we'll be open
through Christmas and actually you know
we've got a great experience on New
Year's Eve night there so again it's a
little little special you know I think
uh normally enchant doesn't do a New
Year's Eve version so this is kind of
enchant and Resort World kind of uh I
would say like New Year's ease and izing
the the whole experience so great place
to watch fireworks great place to I know
it's a little later to even bring the
kids and and just like another added
element to an already great like holiday
experience now picture this you and your
friend sip in champagne in a luxury
Igloo overlooking the strip that's what
I call a unique and Chic holiday you
know the igloos are just a very
different and special experience you
know when I when I look at you know we
basically got a blend canvas in the Rose
rooftop and we kept trying to find the
right partner to activate the space with
and you know the team over at Luke came
to me last year with with an idea he had
me at boov but that's not
this year we had a Bluetooth speakers we
added a small TV so you can watch your
favorite holiday movie we've got a
selection of games so it's really about
coming in there consuming time hanging
out with good friends having an intimate
Journey on top of a rooftop in Las Vegas
which again the space itself is super
unique and you know New Year's Eve I I'm
gonna I'm gonna go out and say I think
it's probably the best location to watch
fireworks on New Year's Eve outside of
the ability to book the igloos which
again you can book in a two-hour
duration you can do that directly from
the Resort World Main webpage you
actually can even just walk up here and
grab a drink so the bar is open to just
come up and grab a drink we do have some
fire pits we have a voove cafe area so
again if you're looking for something
more intimate small two top we have it
we have some fire pits up here as well
and while you strut or frolic the
Resorts World you know whatever your
holiday mood is keep in mind the gifts
are not underneath the Christmas tree
they're behind secret doors we have a
speakeasy called here kitty kitty which
during the holiday season turns into
pure Christmas Kitty uh and again it's
it's a fun overly decored bar that has a
great Mixology program award-winning
mixologist that have essentially curated
different cocktails and craft cocktails
for the holiday season fun entry point a
lot of photo moments in a very small
space very shareable elements and just
honestly a great way to have a larger
group or have an intimate feel and again
has that element of secrecy that makes
it even a little bit more fun from cool
and cozy to glamorous and classic thanks
to Hilton Resorts world you can be the
star of their Hallmark holiday movie
well at least it feels like a movie and
this was something that they only do in
a few cities Nationwide so when they
came to us we obviously thought it was a
super interesting opportunity it was a
great way to convert one of our rooms to
really I would say entangle into the
holiday experience and you know what
walking through the room it really is it
makes you feel like it's Christmas every
morning which is just a great feel and
we all know everyone enjoys those great
Hallmark Christmas movies so again and
that's kind of part of the package as
well that wraps up the holiday
experiences but the gift that keeps
giving at Resorts World is entertainment
it's an award-winning lineup you know
that we put it all on a board it looks
more like a global Festival than a
Resort in Las Vegas yep that sounds like
a New Year's Eve to remember when you
look at from Kevin Hart in the showroom
to the enchant installation to fireworks
viewing from the igloos to Tiësto to
Pitbull to different experiences on
property from Jalisco to alion 66
there's just so many different
opportunities for you to make Resort
World your home on New Year's Eve all
information for all experiences are
going to be right on our website we've
got our own New Year's Eve website and
again we're really looking at activating
the entirety of this property like our
goal is you come to Resort World on New
Year's Eve and it feels like you're in
Times Square in New York